[музика]
снимай чуть-чуть зараз а ты можеш
поснимать
[музика]
А в нас
буде Доброго здоров'я
[музика]
всімці друзі Вітаємо вас в етерії вашої
улюбленої late Night Show міжнародної
the Week і наш сьогоднішній гість п'ятий
президент України Петро Порошенко
вітаюні телеглядачі Вітаємо вас і в нашу
програму
і з поверненням з вашої недавньої
північно-американської подорожі але
хотів би почати з ваших вражень щодо
вчорашньої прес-конференції президента
Володимира Зеленського який вчергове
мало говорив про Володимира Путіна Але
багато про Порошенка навіть сказав що ви
втратили Донбас Що ви на це можете
сказати Вітаю Пітер Вітаю Тарас Я дуже
дякую Що запросили цій суботній вечір
і ну дуже важко це коментувати насправді
чого чекає українське суспільство від
підсумкової
прес-конференції Зеленського де він
долає
екватор і вже як кажуть в Україні не йде
на базар а вже повертається з
базару
чекають спокою чекають відповіді на
питання чекають щоби те що зараз обурює
суспільство президент
заспокоїв
врешті-решт я не коментую випадищо до
мене це не нове він ці скоро вже три
роки прожив з моїм ім'ям Він встає з
моїм ім'ям Він лягає і я думаю що це вже
справа скажемо так е сфіофанії яку він
обіцяв передати е дітям але як завжди е
пожартував щоб сімейний лікар сфіофанії
прийшов до нього до державну дачу яку
він теж обіцяв передати дітям і теж
пожартував нехай вони там розбираються
але коли ми говоримо про те що
відбувалося на війні і як звільнявся
Донбас то звичайно з 14го до 19 років Це
були дуже важкі часи
і під час війни можливо не можливо а і
команда робило і певні помилки і певні
прорахунки і я точно хо маю вибачитись
перед родинами загиблих українських
героїв за ці помилки і прорахунки але уж
точно не
зеленському задавати мені питання як
Українські збройні сили і я як верховний
головнокомандувач звільняв Донбас не
зеленському який чотири рази тікав від
мобілізації не зеленському який під час
того як як я був в окупованому Луганську
в 100 метрах від захопленого будинку СБУ
як я під час кампанії був візваріно яке
вже тоді було захоплено
російськими так званими
прикордонниками а він фотографувався в
той час на червоній площі в
Москві
або в Горлівці уже під час
окупації був там такий Бес
і він за замовленням цього беса в палаці
культуру
ірола грав свої абсолютно
безвкусні корпоративи для сепаратистів в
той час коли прямо там в 100 метрах від
цього вбивали Володимира рибака в
окупованій Горлівці він жартував щодо
захоплення українських танків не йому
задавати ці питання і в цих умовах
безумовно вночі мене
Розбуди я вам скажу коли і як Українські
збройні сили добровольчі підрозділи
звільняли під керівництвом Верховного
головнокомандувача Порошенко
Лисичанськ
Северодонецк
славянськ тоді ще
Дзержинськ Маріуполь
Я не знаю Краматорськ
костянтинівку І 2/тре окупованого
Донбасу Я пишаюся тим що так ми
зруйнували план Путіна побудови
Новоросії на базі дев'яти областей
України і Ну звичайно мені було б цікаво
А за 2, по роки а який населений пункт
звільнив пан Зеленський
перед тим як задавати мені
питання може нагадати підписане ним так
зване розведення військ де він здав
українську землю политою кров'ю
українських воїнів для того щоби
прибігти і зараз мені задавати це
питання можу нагадати що в той час коли
українські воїни воювали він Вибачте на
слові членам на роялі
грав і сьогодні небирається наглості
задавати мені питання не вам задавати ці
питання Володимир
Олександрович Петре олексійовичу Давайте
поговоримо про міжнародний контекст
ситуації на українських кордонах ми
спостерігаємо угруповання російських
військ яке налічує на сьогоднішній
момент понад 100 000 близько 100 000
військових і про це прямо кажуть
сьогодні представники західних розвідок
зрештою три тижні після заперечень це
визнала і українська сторона нагадаю
перед тим Секретар Ради національної
безпеки і оборони Олексій Данілов кілька
разів називав Це дезінформацію в тому
числі те що опублікували впливові
американське видання Poli The Washington
Post в світлі цього готується зустріч
президентів США і Росії про це прямо
вказують в МЗС Російської Федерації
зокрема заступник Лаврова пан рябков
каже що така зустріч на сьогоднішній
день готується український контекст те
що раніше було ми пам'ята знаємо за
вашою каденції нічого без України про
Україну На жаль цього разу швидше за все
буде порушений
наскільки небезпечно є ситуація цього
разу і чим вона може відрізнятися від
того що було весною 2021 року Ну
по-перше я Хочу наголосити що це аж ніяк
не початок вторгнення Україна живе
вмовах війни і ще раз Хочу наголосити я
це під креслював пть років своєї
каденції що це ніякий не конфлікт на
сході і навіть не конфлікт з Росією
це збройна агресія Російської Федерації
проти суверенної незалежної держави
України чим це відрізняється від подій
які відбувалися весною цього
року і я прокоментував це перед поїздкою
в Галіфакс хочу нагадати
що перші публікаці які з'явилися в
Вашингтон пост з'явилися 30
жовтня і одразу вже через дві години
українські Влада офіс президента і
Міністерство оборони заперечила
категорично відкинувши назвавши ці
публікації
провокації тоді наші партнери Сполучених
Штатів Америки Вже наступного дня 1
жовтня в політику
оприлюднили
селайтфото з доказами присутності
російської військової техніки
причому Хочу наголосити що ця техніка є
досить
специфічна бо може кількість
військовослужбовців Російської Федерації
зросла незначно але абсолютно нові і
сучасна розвідувальна техніка засоби
радіоелектронної боротьби і аж до
балістичних ракет малого радіосудії
іскандер були доставлені під час навчань
захід-21 і залиши
в Росії чи в Білорусі вони це були точно
на території Російської Федерації
причому особовий склад розташований був
на відстані 250-300 км і Хочу наголосити
що бути передислокований цей особовий
склад може бути за 2-3
години вночі в умовах забезпечення
відповідної
конфіденційності підготовки удару з за
ці роки Росія побудувала залізницю
побудувала дороги побудувала аеродроми
побудувала все всю логістику яка може
бути здійснена різка зласла кількість
Танків і бронетехніки а з дивним
поняттям українська влада звинуватила
наших американських британських
партнерів партнерів з НАТО в свідомому
розповсюдженні дезінформації що можна
було зрозуміти аж ніяк і після цього
були публікації в blomberg публікації в
rйс публікації в asшиed Press публікації
в New York Times
скрізь і знову не находило це
підтвердження серед української влади і
аж допоки Міністр закордонних справ
кулеєба разом з яєрмаком приїхали до
Сполучених Штатів і в держдепі і в Раді
безпеки Сполучених Штатів були
продемонстровані переконливі докази і
під час спільної прес-конференції
вперше українська влада наважилася в
Вашингтоні підтвердити це що
відбувається
зараз під час зустрічі в галіфаксі а там
було вісім чотирьохзіркових генералів
починаючи від
командера unedat specialeration Forces
Спецназ і
завершуючи United States EOS починаючи
від командувача United States coats
guardard берегової охорони і завершуючи
Національну гвардію починаючи ну короше
це було топові вищі керівництво збройних
сил Сполучених Штатів Америки ми мали
можливість детально поспілкуватися з
ними і головна позиція разом з
конгресменами і сенаторами яке там було
дуже велике
представництво чи чим допомогти питання
що ми можемо
зробити запити від
України деталізовано з графіком з усім
що ми терміново
чекаємо на жаль ми поки що не бачимо або
принаймні не підтверджено що це буде
здійснена поставка і я наголошую що якщо
правда що ми для того щоби зупинити
Путіна ми маємо різко підняти ціну яку
Путін заплатить за вторгнення в Україну
і наголошую що це єдиний спосіб зупинити
Путіна на жаль поки що я вимушений
констатувати що українська влада діє
неефективно Я це кажу не для того щоб
прокритикувати я навпаки зараз час коли
українське суспільство має перед
загрозою вторгнення Путіна об'єднатися і
Я готовий весь свій досвід Я готовий всі
свої зв'язки терміново задіяти для того
щоби підвищити ціну для Путіна якщо він
нападе і на сьогоднішній день ми точно
маємо отримати Сполучених Штатів
починаючи від контрбатарейних станцій
для підвищення ефективності дій
української артилерії і завершуючи
станціями радіоелектронної боротьби
починаючи від зенітних ракет patріotт і
завершуючи е сучасними е defensive
weapons які конче потребує Українські
збройні сили ми різко можемо збільшити
обсяг військової допомоги і це не лише
Сполучені Штати а й великабританія
Франція і інші країни НАТО які вже
заявили про це і ми поки що гаємо час от
в мене питання як і навіщо ми згаяли ці
три тижні коли українська влада замість
того щоб бити в колоколи їздити
організовувати спеціальне засідання ради
безпеки організації об'єднаних націй
термінові телефонні консультації позиції
щодо постійних представників
ОБСЄ термінові консультації в НАТО для
того
щоби нам все це забрати і завершуючи ну
друзі припинить нарешті красти гроші на
дорогах і перекиньте ці гроші щоби
забезпечити грошове забезпечення
українських
військовослужбовців заправ відсутнім
дизельним пальним танки і
бронетехніку забезпечте ударні дрони До
речі їх також треба включити в то що нам
сьогодні конче потребує В мене є
абсолютно детальний план який представив
в галіфаксі що саме Україна потребує для
того щоб це зробити у відповідь на
численні запити бо захід готовий нам
допомогти захід готовий бути разом з
нами причому допомогти не так як деякі
вважають що вони направлять своїх солдат
які мають воювати разом з українцями Ні
ми воювати можемо самі ми створили армію
Я пишаюся цим але
е підвищити ефективність е відсічі
російської агресії ми це можемо зробити
за дуже короткий термін а Петри
Олексійович але ви Я впевнений що ви
чули про те що окремі західні експерти
наполягають що можливим є розмін США з
Росією України на Тайвань А тобто США
нібито можуть поступитися Україною
натомість сконцентруватись на збереженні
Незалежності тайбея А І що б ви від
відповіли б на такі прогнози дивіться я
не експерт я лідер української опозиції
я п'ятий президент України
Я дуже багато працював з президентом
Сполучених Штатів діючим тодішнім
віце-президентом джозефом
байденом Я маю величезну кількість
друзів в американському конгресі і в
палаті представників і в сенаті і я можу
наголосити що
Україна Ще з 14го року мною було
сформовано bypan Support Freedom and
Democracy in Ra і свободи і демократії в
Україні і ніхто не дозволить вести якісь
підкилимні переговори розміну і здачі
інтересів України це не зробить
Американський президент Джо баййден це
не зробить американський уряд і це не
зробить американський конгрес і в мене
прохання що єдине що Україна зараз
потребує це звернутися чітко по допомогу
а на сьогоднішній Мені здається що
навпаки В закриті українські двері
стукаються Наші друзі і партнери
намагаючись
зрозуміти друзі А що ж вам потрібно і
саме це питання мені задавали в Галіфакс
і моя відповідь була дуже проста питання
номер один прийміть р рішення про
пдч бо надання України плана дій щодо
членства в НАТО це ще не
членство це є програма дорожня карта
реформ які мають бути здійснені так як я
це зробив під час своєї каденції по
безвізовому режиму так так само зараз
треба зробити щодо плану дії щодо
членства в НАТО надання Україні плана
дії щодо членства в НАТО це є перемога
свободного світу не надання України Це є
перемога Путіна повірте мені Перемоги
Путіна сьогодні ніхто не вбачаю це
перший пункт другий пункт - це санкції
мають бути вже зараз оприлюднені перелік
санкцій які застосує світ і ми це
обговорили лише позавчора під час моєї
дуже там трьохгодинної зустрічі з
послами сімки плюс Євросоюз де питання
санкцій питання можливих ефективних
кроків було серед основних під час цього
я знаю що ви наполягаєте на
необхідності дійти аж до відключення
Росії від системи сwift Я вважаю що
список санкцій має бути дуже болючий іце
ще один інструмент для того щоб
підвищити ціну Яка Росія заплатить якщо
вона перетне червоні лінії в тому числі
і свіф позиція третя це є енергетична
безпека включно з санкціями по
північному потоку2 і вони вже мають бути
застосовані зараз і я твердо переконаний
що ми можемо це забезпечити найближчим
часом четверта позиція - це поставлення
defensive Weapon оборонної зброї Про які
я вже сьогодні сказав і Отже е пдч
санкції енергетика е поставка ее
оборонної зброї це є ті факти які можна
прийняти рішення протягом тижня і це
точно буде дамоклов міч який буде вісити
над Путіним якщо він зійде з розум
і буде атакувати продовжити атакувати
Україну і тоді відповідаючи на запит а
чи буде Атака А чи нападе Путін моя
відповідь ніхто в світі не знає чому
Тому що сам Путін не знає якщо це буде
велика ціна яку він заплатить Путін не
нападе якщо буде бездіяльність України
якщо буде бездіяльність світу то Путін
зайде так далеко як йому дозволять ще
раз наголошую Ми українці не дозволимо
це зробити це вже кардинально інша
ситуація ми маємо армію ми маємо зброю
ми
маємо гроші і я Хочу наголосити що зараз
ситуація набагато впевненіше і я і
україна себе почуває ніж в 14-му році і
коли ми говорили знову таки Про вчорашню
прес-конференцію то
Е чого чекали українці українці чекали
перш за все звіту А що зроблено за 2 1
по роки це вже час коли не можна кювати
на попередників це вже час коли треба
звітувати самому Хочу наголосити що під
час свого екватору Коли я звітував це
була не тільки підписана угода про
асоціацію та поглиблену та всеохоплюючу
зону вільної торгівлі чого вимагав
Революція Гідності Це була не просто
підписання вже на той час безвізового
режиму для українських громадян
якій уже запроваджувався 11 червня 17го
року це була не тільки створена армія
збройні сили України Це була не за
тільки забезпечення сталого економічного
розвитку це було не тільки створення
антикорупційної інфраструктури Це була
не тільки імплементація децентралізації
Це була не тільки незалеж сть
енергетична коли в 15-му році ми
припинили купляти і російську
електроенергію і російський газ це була
велика кількість речей які були зроблені
за першу половину каденції але Петро
зараз вже це все вже не є актуальним От
вчора на прес-конференції президент
Зеленський заявив що виходу немає ніж
купляти наприклад електроенергію в
Білорусі і він запропонував сказав що
якщо у вас є альтернатива відключити
якесь місто від електроенергії або
купити в Білорусі ми будемо купляти в
Білорусі як нам переконати західних
союзників в тому що вони мають
запроваджувати санкції якщо ми
купляємо електроенергію у партнера
Путіна моя відповідь пане з це друга
позиція щодо прес-конференції люди
хотіли не тільки почути що зроблено а й
почути яка стратегія країни і вищого
політичного керівництва країни що робити
моя відповідь дуже проста Якщо ти не
знаєш
зізнаюся запроси допомогу склич РНБО з
питань енергетики запроси керівників
парламентських фракцій треба будь ласка
Я
готовий прийти допомогти і пояснити яким
чином ми в набагато більш складних
умовах відключили російську
електроенергію і
відключили припинили купляти російський
газ бо з країні він має пояснити А чому
були вкрадені кошти наку нафтагаз
замість того щоб закупити газ тоді б не
було проблем А чому е пан Коломойський
разом з паном Зеленським його
бізнес-партнерами таким чином
організували роботу центренерго коли
вони спалили вугілля купляли його за
супердорогою ціною а коломойському
відпускали електроенергію за півціни в
такий спосіб запровадивши збитки на
багато-багато мільярдів гривень от що
робити
зараз я наголошую ми свого часу зробили
все можливе для того щоби завести з
усього світу вугілля починаючи від
Сполучених Штатів Америки і закінчуючи
Австралію починаючи від Польщі і тоді
коли Путін припинив постачати нам
вугілля ми ж це все проходили ми знаємо
як тут діяти що ми почули на вчорашній
прес-конференції
що виноват люди виявляється вони мали
закупляти вугілля виявляється вони мали
закупляти все необхідне і на
сьогоднішній день це поразка в чи
визнання власної безпорадності ми
наголошуємо що закупівля електроенергії
в Білорусі - це пастка побачите Білорусь
припинить нам постачати електроенергію
при температурі -15- -20 щоб саме зараз
підсидивши на на голку вдарити щоб було
ще ще більш болюче Петре олексійовичу ви
згадали ще раз повертаючись до
прес-конференції звісно Вона майже
почалася з того того скандального
розслідування беленкет щодо так званого
вагнергейту Це був справжній скандал
який досі триває ви саме були тоді в
Канаді і свої свідчення коли свої
свідчення о прилюднив тоді колишній
керівник головного управління розвтки
мінобороди Василь бурба ви также
згадували що що мали зустріч з послами
великої сімки та Євросоюзу ваше відчуття
як на заході сприйняли цей скандал і
повертаючись до того що сказав
Український президент він назвав це
операцію товарища Пет а я його цитую що
таким чином вы меня хотели посодить с
эрдоганом а я бы никогда бы не въехал в
эту
стену володимирвич Я вам не
Петя і припинить будь ласка цю практику
невихованої людини
дивіться знов таки я много багато можу
пробачити будь-кому як
християнин як віруюча людина і як
вихована людина
але те
що вчора він на пан Зеленський
намолотив мене не може не
обурювати неважливо як він мене назвав Я
ще раз кажу це відкинемо А коли він
еліту збройних
сил назвав
авантюристами першу оцінку дав До речі
Христа Грозів і його партнер по
розслідуванняю які дуже нам допомогли
хінс йго звати Да е хідінс які дуже нам
допомогли і в mh17 в розслідувані а ви з
ними спілкувались чи з христогроз
Я з Кристо спілкувався Я його знаю і я
вважаю що це є ну ще раз кажу людина яка
в найважчі часи допомогла нам протидіяти
інформаційній війні Росії коли Росія
дала 20 версій як був збитий українцями
m17 білінкет був рішучим коли Росія
звинуватувала звинувачувала нас е в
нападах і наступі то саме білінкет довів
обстріли наших збройних сил з території
Російської Федерації відоме його
розслідування щодо навального проти
Путіна і коли хрісто вчора за підсумками
прес-конференції сказав що йому соромно
за українського президента то на жаль
соромно має бути всім нам чому соромно в
усіх країнах від Сполучених Штатів до
Росії розвідка
Це ті кого носять на руках
роз чому Бо їх життя пов'язано з тим що
Ану пійди за лінію фронта в умовах коли
до зубів озброєне оснащене ФСБ контролює
кожен
крок Проведи низку операцій
і Ну я передбачаю що пан Зеленський
думає що у нас І Захарченко і метерола і
Гіві і дрьмов і местовий багато-багато
покінчили життя самогубством я не
виключаю
цього але під дуже ретельним
спостереженням з боку українських
розвідників і це звичайно що в той час
Зеленський займався чимось іншим а
Уявіть собі що це ніякими грошима
ніякими зарплатами ніякими пільгами
ніякими званнями ніякими орденами ти це
не замотивуєш крім одного любові до
України і от люди заплечіми яких
стоїть блискучі операції які свого часу
зруйнували проект
Путіна пан Зеленський наважився
їх називати
авантюристами це образа для всіх
розвідників більш того це образа для
всіх воїнів
це означає що він не розуміє не поважає
і не любить українську армію
і звичайно що ну краще він мовчав
і я думаю що вчора на прес-конференції
українськей суспільство хотіло отримати
відповіді спочатку звіт Що ти зробив а
друге відповіді на ті питання які
сьогодні з'явилися у суспільства
відповіді на питання як
Чому він спільно з коломойським відмивав
гроші які були вкрадені вкладників
ПриватБанку і оприлюднені в
розслідуванні всесвітньо відомої позиції
Pandora papers ще раз наголошую Це не
про офшора це про спільну крадіжку
відмивання і несплату податків з
десятків і десятків мільйонів доларів
які ще не всі
оприлюднені про це мовчить пан
Зеленський вже більше
місяця пояснити ситуацію приватни хто їх
буде
розслідувати комісія бізулей де
зібралися всі з конфліктами інтересів
вісім слуг з однією метою відмити рмака
і відмити
Зеленського
пояснити в який спосіб
ти на святий день Революції гідності
влаштував
ці незграбності з гелікоптерами
мчсівськими чи ми щось почули з цього
приводу чи були отримані якісь відповіді
Ні ми почули жорстку і агресивну атаку
на журналістів в нас було тільки два
журналісти там які
е мали добре відношення пана Зеленського
це представник канала 1+1 який ніякого
відношення до нього і до олігархів немає
і канал дом який існує за рахунок коштів
платників податків
Е я до речі хочу висловити слова
підтримки
ее
кореспонденці прямого каналу які який
так
позвірячудзуба отримала забо Да з якими
так позвірячому поводилися пан
Зеленський і його
мардавороти от в цих умовах безумовно що
ця прес-конференція викликає серйозне
занепокоєння не тільки в українських
громадян не тільки в українських
журналістів не тільки в українських
громадських діячів не тільки в
українських бо бо це не повага до людей
А І в наших міжнародних партнерів бо
вони потребували пояснення що же
відбувається і На жаль ні українські
громадяни ні українські журналісти ні
наші іноземні партнери відповіді на
питання які їх хвилювали не отримали а з
Порошенко чи там з іншими
це питання окремих фобій пана зеленсько
історія із вагнергейтом триває її
висвітлюють сьогодні всі провідні
світові медіа на превеликий жаль вона
отрує Імідж України в цілому світі і
президент замість того аби вийти і всі
чекали після оприлюдненяго розслідування
бенкет дати чіткі відповіді на те чи є
справді кроти в його оточенні чи бодай
він спробує провести справедливе
розслідування допитати всіх учасників
сумнозвісної наради в офісі Президента
де було ухвалене рішення стосовно
скасування цієї операції каже про пуч
пуч який готують зловісні сили і таке
інше водночас ми знаємо що всі попередні
роки українська розвідка справді
займалася проведенням блискучих операцій
це оцінки багатьох світох експертів в
тому числі Христа грозєва який дав
найвищі оцінки і військові розвитці
Україні і служби безпеки України
АА значна частина цих спецоперацій
готувалася за часів вашого президентства
певно ви не маєте можливості це
коментувати з цілком зрозумілих
природніх причин але чи здатні зараз
українські спецслужби при нинішньому
Верховному гокомандувачі чи Вони досі
здатні проводити операції такого рівня
як наприклад викрадення цемаха чи
операція з вагнергейта яка насправді
була успішною хоча би в тій частині що
по-перше А зібрані досьє понад 300
російських військових злочинців і вони
нікуди не ділись а друге операція ж таки
дала відповідь що кріт в оточенні
президента таки є а може і не один виба
чити що на жаль
після 19го року після
приходу до влади пана
Зеленського я можу наголосити що замість
трагічної операції
по здобуттю і переведенню пана цемаха
який мав бути одним із основних свідків
в процесі проти Росії і Путіна в газі
який був так бездарно і незаконно
переданий Росії що зіпсував наші
стосунки не тільки з голландією не
тільки з міжнародною слідчою групою
попмh-17
но і з НАТО це була абсолютно безглудний
вчинок Я хотів би нагадати що Під час
цієї операції загинув український
герой А зараз
розвідники втрачають
мотивацію подивиться і це не тільки
операція по вагнеровцям подивиться
операція яка відбулася по
підготовки звільнення українських
заручників на Донецькому заводу ізоляції
де Кріт той самий забезпечив виток
інформації і наказ СБУ атакувати
розвідників на українській території для
того щоб зірвати операцію і врешті-решт
і ця операція була зірвана і ми можемо
говорити про багато операцій але замість
операції по вивезенню цемаха На жаль
українські розвідки зараз ставлять
задачі операції по викраденню
корупціонера чауса і ця операція була
повністю провалена спричинивши великий
політичний скандал і зіпсувавши
можливість для нашого політичного
партнера Маї Санду сформувати
конституційну більшість от ціна
некомпетентності Хаоса і
безвідповідальності української влади
А якщо ви Спитаєте мене
яким має бути одним словом висловлена
моя реакція на вчорашню прес-конференцію
Вона була дуже одна проста задовбала
брехня бо по кожному питанню є суцільна
брехня яку вже ніхто не вірить і це вже
не про відосіки і те вже не про це цеце
брехня яку намагається не поважаючи
українцям вішити їм лукшину на вухо і це
ще бі більше дає мені всі підстави
вимагати розслідування до речі для того
щоб не дати їм замовчати Після того як я
рік прочекав
е в умовах їхньої бездіяльності я
наголосив що незважаючи на цілком
таємний характер я наголошую без
розкриття деталій що це я санкціонував
цю операцію по затримки вагнеровців і
Хочу наголосити незважаючи на те що я це
сказав с місяців тому жодного і
готовність свою дати покази хоч в СБУ
хоч в дбр жодного разу з цього приводу я
допитаний не був я був допитаний по
томасу я був допитаний по Керченській
протоці я був допитаний по надання
наказу на кортернаступ єдине питання яке
їх не цікавить - це вагнеровці
і я думаю що на жаль єдине поки що в
чому я звинувачую це в брехні і в тому
що вони не виявляють крота Як ви
правильно сказали але якщо далі це буде
так продовжуватися то не залишається
іншого виходу щоби задати питання
зеленському чо він чого він особисто
покриває зрадників Невже він сам зрадник
Пане президенте і таке
загальносвітоглядне питання Путіну за
останні роки вдалося нав'язати частині
західного західних Еліт наротив про те
що гроші важливіші за цінності бабло
побеждает і зло і добро і все стальноє І
що взагалі правди немає Живемо ми
стосовно відомому вам професору тіметі
снайдеру в світі пост Правди і Путіну
бадеж якого підтримувати на загаді
ліворадикалів або ультраправих взагалі
як ви пам'ятаєте мабуть в 15-му році ви
виступали в моїй моєй альмаматері
колумбійському університеті А і
підстіни тоді прийшли протестувати з
прапорами угруповань ОРД
деякі там анархісти ліворадикали
нью-йоркські і ваш покірний слуга
опинився в Епіцентрі тих подій ба більше
спровоховав штовханину ось До речі як це
було
Ну і моє питання іноді здається що
Україні нема чого пропонувати заходу
окрім опілювання до спільних цінностей
але в Європі цінності не стоять на місці
вони змінюється так і змінюється за
допомогою Росії от в цих
умовах чи можна подолати і як можна
подолати цю втому від України Про яку
говорять по-перше Я Хочу наголосити що
ніякої хтоми від Україні немає це
наратив який розповсюджується Путіним
який називається
raфattig і якщо ви найдете і маєте
можливість спілкуватися з політиками то
мені це вдалося долати і під час
міграційної кризи 15го року мені це
вдалося долати і під час надання безвізу
в 17му 16му17му роках і що до
продовження співпраці включно з
макрофінансовою допомогою з боку
євросоюза всі е конec
е роки мого президентства е Разом з тим
питання Money Matter тобто пріоритет
грошам а не цінностям на відміну від
values Matter це є одним із елементів
гібридної війни яка раніше Путіном
велася проти України а сьогоднішній день
подивитьсяся вона ведеться проти Європи
Саме те що Ми попереджали з самого
початку агресії проти нашого держави
бо міграційна криза яка організована
сьогодні на кордоні балтійських країн і
Польщі з боку біларусі бо ситуація в
Боснії і герцеговіні коли ця балканська
країна знаходиться під реальною загрозою
припинення існування втручання в вибори
значної
кількості європейських країн з боку
Російської Федерації означає одне
е Путін робить атаку на цінності
цілісність і
єдність європейських країн і
трансатлантичну єдність сполученими
штатами з Канади і тоді коли мене питали
в 14му-15му роках А чого ж Україна
потребує від Європейського Союзу я казав
дві речі і це не гроші хоча нам гроші
дуже потрібні і це не в нас є позиція
нам потрібна єдність Європейського Союзу
всі 28 голосів мають голосувати
синхронно і Солідарність з Україною ту
Тоді би цього добилися і я твердо
переконаний що можемо отримати зараз бо
якщо ти не є оптимістом ти не маєш бути
президентом воюючої країни бо ти точно
програєш якщо ти не маєш волю до
перемоги І от Сьогодні я повернувшись з
Європейського турне повернувшись з
Канади зараз планую відвідати Сполучені
Штати Америки з однією метою відновлення
проукраїнської коаліції після ковідної
перерви
і ми ще раз кажу Зеленський просто мій
опонент Мій ворог так само як і ворог
Європи так і ворог всього вільного світу
це Путін А от тепер якщо ви кажете val
смети то цінності у нас асоціюються з
Європейським Союзом так чи ні Угу в
Конституції в тому числі моєю командою
було записано що основною метою
діяльності державної влади
зовнішньополітичним орієнтиром є членст
Євросоюзі і на і НАТО членство в
Євросоюзі і НАТО можливо лише тоді коли
Україна буде відповідати копенгагенським
критеріям це навіть Ну переговорів не
ведеть подивиться бо я думаю що
українська влада і Зеленський зокрема
зеленої гадки немає про що йдеться що є
номером один в копенгагенських критеріях
демократія демократія - це є вільні
вибори чи наблизились ми до вільних
виборів після 19-го року навпаки після
виборів на 87му році коли СБ окрузі коли
СБУ вскриває мішки з бюлетенями крадеце
після скупки голосів які ми бачили хоч в
Черкасах хоч в Херсоні ми на
сьогоднішній день відкотилися в
демократії Хто за це відповідає пан
Зеленський друга позиція це є
верховенство права Хіба у нас після того
як Зеленський ввів Смірнова татарова
Єдині два суди які були сформовані за
моєю безпосередньою участю це верховний
суд і вищий антикорупційний суд на
сьогоднішній день мають довіру вся решта
там де
пан Вовк і прикриваючий його Зеленський
заблокував судову реформу і на
сьогоднішній день іде повна руйнація по
верховенство права є відкат питання
Третє це є Свобода ЗМІ друзі мої Ну те
що зараз відбувається то це мені точно
нагадує пам'ятаєш тараз рух стоп цензури
всередині правління Януковича от зараз
ми маємо абсолютно тотожні Повтори і по
тільки зараз солідарності журналістів
менше стало очевидно і зараз по відкату
свободи слова третій пункт
копенгагенських критеріїв ми відкатилися
питання четверте це є Свобода пра прав
точніше права людини якщо ви маєте
проблеми з правами людини а ми маємо
різке зростання кількості звернень до
Європейського Суду з прав людини
позасудове засудження яке
організовується Зеленським і
його з біговіськом то це є знову нас
відкидає друзі так може замість того щоб
пред'являти претензії Меркель чому
Україна досі не в Євросоюзі Ви хоч
подивитесь і скажете як Україна має
робити свою домашню роботу і в цих
умовах безумовно дуже важливо зараз
політична активність
громадська активність небайдужих людей
які доведуть те про що казав Пітер вес
metте не дати жодного шансу путінському
moneyмеa тобто пріоритет грошей коли він
буде просто купляти за російські гроші
російський наратив і п'яту колону
всередині нашої держави Принаймні я і Як
лідер опозиції Як лідер європейської
солідарності зроблю все можливе для того
щоби зруйнувати цей сценарій якому
свідомо чи Несвідомо підіграє пан
Зеленський ми маємо захистити Україну Ну
але Росія на жаль не приховує своїх
планів буквально днями ми побачили низку
статей які були написані очільниками
російської влади колишній Помічник і
колишній заступник глави адміністрації
російського президента пан Сурков
написав свою статтю яка називається
м Дай Боже пам'яті е
Возвращение стабільності здається щось
таке після нього дав велике інтерв'ю
аргументам і фактам Николай патрушев де
пообіцяв що в Україні скоро полхне так
що побіжать з України мільйони біженців
звісно куди до Європи А ще один
заступник пана патрушева пан гребнкін
взагалі сказав що українська влада
звісно нелегітимна більше того вона
зараз буде організовувати теракти іде в
окупованому Криму вбивати кримчан і це
може стати приводом для казус Беллі АА
але де реакція української влади і
наскільки вона взагалі знаходиться в
адекватному стані щоб зрозуміти розмір
загроз Перед якими йми поставили знаєте
для мене це питання достатньо
несподіване але я дозволю стати собі на
захист української влади бо намагаюсь
бути
об'єктивним Я не вважаю за необхідне
реагувати на
псевдофілософські і псевдо ітелектуальні
опуси людини у якого руки полокоть в
українській крові пана
Суркова
бо виконавцем путінської волі
щодо агресії на Донбасі
є пан
цурков бо з одного боку він
парафував документи засадничі Мінського
процесу яки передбачав виведення
іноземних вій вік
виведення важкої техніки артилерії
звільнення
заручників запровадження діяльності
українських органів влади і після цього
проведення місцевих виборів при
непроведенні державних є пан црков і
зараз коли цей ну Вибачте за не
телевізійне і не парламентське слово
бред коли Росія може існувати лише в
умовах
агресії Я Хочу наголосити що через
санкції через опір України Росія вже
заплатила достатньо високу ціну і ще
Заплати Подивіться 8 років в Росії немає
економічного зростання Подивіться за 8
років рівень життя росіян впав на 25% в
той час як скрізь росте і це незалежно
від рівня цін на нафту цю державу
бензоколонку
і за такі опуси пана
Суркова
платить вся мільйонна
Росія патрушев це
абсолютно скажемо так з
одного з одної з однієї команди я там не
знаю коли він літав в Оман І про що вони
там говорили чи не говорили чи з єрмаком
чи з Зеленським коли Зеленський обіцяв
нам що він з омана привезе чи то 10 чи
то 30 млярдів доларов інвестицій а
статистика за два роки показує надійшло
нуль але я наголошую на тому що розмови
хоч з паном црковим хоч з паном
патрошевим вічнавіч абсолютно марна
справа тому якщо відповісти дуже коротко
не читайте статті пана Суркова ви
змушені бо це наша робота Добре тоді
читайтеце є краі письменники знайте їх
але не розповсюджуйте Я впевнений що ми
достатньо здорові суспільство для того
щоби мати щеплення не лише від
коронавірусу а й щеплення від подібної
отрути які розповсюджують російські
ястриби в українському інформаційному
середовищі Отже Пане президенте Ми
багато з вами провели спільних
конференцій Де ви були учасниками
висвітливали їх і в давосі і в Мюнхені і
в інших столицях а для нас дуже важливо
щоб українська міжнародна програма була
присутня на українському телебаченні і
завдяки тому що телеканал прямий нас
стерпить уже протягом чотирьох років Ми
займаємося дечому невдячною справою ми
висвітлюємо міжнародну політику дехто
каже що міжнародка українців не цікавить
але наш досвід з пітером спілкування з
нашими багатьма глядачами переконують в
іншому Що би ви побажали як сам
міжнародник як випускник міжнародного
університету міжнародній програмі за
Віки 4тири роки - це знакова подія в
умовах коли програми зникають і
з'являються 4отири роки це вже як певний
Знак якості Отже Дозвольте мені
привітати вас з цією річницею привітати
вас шановні глядачі з тим що ви маєте
величезну і унікальну можливість
дивитися програму яка проповідує в
Україні європейські цінності проповідує
Європу в Україні і тягне Україну в
Європі це дуже знакова подія п'ятий
президент України Петро Порошенко